hey everyone and welcome to generation
next now a few weeks ago we talked about
a lot of the problems that the
playstation 5 and xbox series x have
been having
since they were released and now we're
more than a month out from launch
and there have been some improvements so
but we definitely talk about those
but also talk about the things that
still need some
work so joining me is xbox expert jordan
remain
yo and playstation pro tomorrow hussein
salutations everyone how are we today
very well
thank you how are you i'm okay
no i'm living i'm good see we know this
is a lie though because he's done this
twice now where he tries to sneak in
something else
part way through the episode or at the
very end just let me flourish jordan
let him flourish all right let's get
into it
intro
so when we did the episode a few weeks
ago it was definitely playstation that
had
uh most of the software problems uh
issues with crashing um even like uh the
ports on the front of the console
not charging controllers uh so tam
has there been an update there has
indeed you'll be very glad to hear that
your control your ports will now be
charging your controllers on the
playstation 5
so sony released version 2
0.20 hyphen 02
i don't know if that's the date of the
whatever it is interlinked
what's happening here but the
the key update text is an issue that
prevented the ps5 wireless controller
from being charged
while in rest mode when connected to the
ps5 front side usb
type a port using the usb cable included
with some ps5 consoles
was resolved that's a fantastic reading
by the way
thank you that was uh that was a patch
speak for
your stupid usb ports network
and you can charge your controllers okay
um but yeah so that was a
an issue and there were a number of
other um improvements
that uh that firmware and a few other
like hotfixes have made
um in the time since but as for that key
which is a pretty
major function a lot of people charge
their controllers using the usb ports
um was resolved and resolved relatively
quickly so kudos to sony on doing that
um in in quick fashion yeah that's
really good i'm very glad that
they fixed that so quickly um so another
thing that has been improved on
since the ps5 has launched are actually
the games themselves so obviously there
have been
um next gen patches and some of them are
kind of
to be expected is like oh yeah you know
you know your game will work via
backwards compatibility but some games
have seen
huge improvements so jordan i'm going to
come to these what are some of the
highlights
i would say the big one i think that a
lot of people will probably care about
the most because it's the most recent
game is spider-man miles morales and now
runs with that smooth
60 fps with ray tracing so which is
really cool
yeah it'll look so much better i'm very
curious to see how that's going to look
with the uh
spider-verse outfit on has anyone made
one of those like you know those dr dot
pictures but with ray romano and called
it ray tracing
is that has that been done yet because
if not boy do i have an idea for you
but uh beyond miles there are a few
other games that have gotten
next-gen improvements uh since the
launch of the playstation
5 console uh borderlands 3 you get the
4k
support 60fps it also now supports a
next-gen uh
what is it called split screen that's
the word split screen with more than two
people so
i guess if you operate right now because
if you happen to live with
more than two people uh before the
quarantine times and so now you're
living with four people and it's like oh
like we can all play borderlands three
together with one
copy of the game uh rocket league
also 4k 60 fps destiny 2
4k 60 fps with 120 fps in the crucible i
feel like i'm going to be a broken
record for most of these because they're
just
all 4k 60fps
and it's nice to have these updates
beyond just
um oh the game runs on the console
it's like maybe you get a better loading
time but i do like the fact that a lot
of devs are
putting in the 4k 60fps the destiny
stuff is genuinely meaningful chris
pereira who's
one of our resident destiny players and
fans has written up something that's
available on the site now about how it's
a meaningful difference for him and he
describes it as being
you know he kind of creates the context
that destiny on pc
destiny 2 on pc specifically is the best
way to play that game
and when he moved between platforms he'd
often feel like
the console versions were broken in some
fashion but now he feels like they're
closer together so you're getting almost
like a pc experience on
destiny and if you play that game a lot
constantly traveling traveling into
orbit down to planets between places the
low terms can become a big issue and he
mentioned that they're down to like 30
seconds which is like
significant and then the frame rate
increases also good so he describes it
as a genuinely meaningful improvement
and
destiny for destiny fans that's amazing
but also like for other games like
borderlands and miles morales they're
all
the technology is finding new
interesting ways to improve experiences
i'm just glad because i think that a lot
of people maybe
more so on the playstation side were
kind of worried that ps4 would be left
behind
because quote unquote sony believes in
generations
um but i'm really glad to see that a lot
of these big developers are continuing
that support onwards
so very good in terms of
improvements to games however
let's let's talk about stability because
i wanted i wanted to kind of
try and do like a more positive spin on
what's been happening
and like while the vast majority of ps5s
are fully like working totally fine
there's been some issues still so
obviously we have issues with stability
i'm still getting crashes seeing a lot
of people on my timelines getting
crashes
and actually a lot of people are saying
it's for spider-man and
miles morales both both of the games so
not great um my boyfriend the other day
i feel so bad
he did a boss fight in demon souls
and like he leveled up four times he was
very proud of himself
the next morning he went on to play and
for some reason the ps
the ps plus cloud save overwrote
his local save instead of uploading his
local save to the cloud
so he lost all of it
it's fine he i i spoke to him and he's
since done the shrine of stone's uh
grind path so he's
he's he's living a charmed life now
you're making me very worried to keep
playing dm
insults until they pass usually yeah you
just have to be careful with
i don't think it's a demon souls issue i
think it's a playstation 5
cloud sync playstation plus issue
because every now and then i'll get a
message being like
couldn't sync your cloud save and i'm
like why you've been doing it fine for
the last day
and then you have to like manually force
it to happen um and it's just so just
keep an eye on your notifications is
what i'd say
yeah uh but the other one i wanted to
talk about
and evan i've already preemptively sent
you
the fun pop culture reference i'll make
for this one is
um an error code ce1082551
which in my head i always sing
c e 108 2 5 5 1.
i can't sing isn't that like a video
where the dude's like staring at me
creepy through the window like
yes it was it's a creepy video but the
song is really good
the video is really creepy but whatever
the song slaps but
there is an error code ce108251
where uh you stopped playing a game a
lot of people have been reporting this
with call of duty
um and the like ps5 will crash within
minutes and display
that error code with something went
wrong with this game on app reporting
this error to sony interactive
entertainment helps improve ps5 hardware
software and services
this report might include personal
information uh people who've had it have
been told by sony
to wait for a patch there was a patch uh
last week people on reddit still saying
they have the issue
and one of my favorite things about this
is that it has its own twitter account
i think the most interesting thing part
of this error code is if you've got the
playstation camera plugged in it
actually takes a picture of your face as
it happens
and sends that way as well what what
no okay
like ralph wiggum you can see his body
you said it so
convincingly i would if that was an
option i'd enable that
because then it'd just be loads of
people like and sony said opening it and
just people with middle fingers and two
fingers up and being like
but the thing is when you said that is
because it takes clips now when it sends
everything so that could that's
plausible but anyway remember in burna
paradise when you do a crash it will
take a picture of you and send it to the
other person
like that's what we need with error
codes um
so yeah ce 108251 is a weird one because
sony i don't think have ever actually
formally acknowledged it but there are
still plenty of people online who are
having this issue
and actually the the person who runs uh
ce1082551 on twitter did actually manage
to get replacement from sony
um they have taken his console back so
fingers crossed that gets a fix
but obviously not everything's
not all the kinks are gonna be worked
out in the first six to eight weeks
um but you know that's really sucks
and i hope that everyone else who has
that issue manages to actually get a
replacement because
in the words of jim ryan there's nothing
left
yeah i mean like you know i've always
said it as well we'll we'll give
we'll give sony the benefit of that and
the time because you know we're no king
shaming
kind of uh show king shaming
what have you ever seen that vine it's a
classic vine
it's because lucy said all the kinks
still need to be worked out so my brain
was like come on you can do this you can
do this
there's the vine where it goes kink
shaming is my kick
and then he screams calling people daddy
is gross stop
king shaming me king shaming is my kink
we've talked a bunch about playstation
so there have been some improvements
some fixes some people are still
reporting issues with
having external hard drives whilst other
people are reporting that they are fixed
so it just seems like a bit of a mixed
bag right now
let's move on to xbox because they had a
lovely update
jordan joined us it's so small but yeah
uh
it's a good feature it's a stocking
stuffer they gave us more
like dynamic background options which
admittedly is
i guess this is the terry's chocolate
orange
in your stocking of updates something
that you expect to happen you get it
every year
but you're still happy about it i have
to admit i am very happy about the
new badges the xs badges that they
added to showcase every game that's been
optimized for
uh series x and series s so now whenever
you're just like
browsing through your library of games
you can easily see what games are on
game pass and which games have been
optimized for
next generation there's still room for
another
or maybe even two more badges and i like
the badges xbox keep adding them
you got auto hdr yeah um which
i actually haven't tested it yet i don't
know if either of you have
tried yet a majority of the games that i
am currently
playing on xbox are already optimized
for
series x and series s so i haven't felt
the need to turn on
auto hdr um yeah me too i'm playing
yakuza so
i'm playing tetris effect so
but also but yeah it's cool it's cool
that they added it
but also being able to pre-load upcoming
game pass games
and look at them before they go live is
a fantastic thing
right before i knew about the update i
had just
seen that section i'm like oh my god the
medium and call of the sea they're out
they're just here on
uh game pass and i just download the
full game and i'm like i'm going to
start playing this and it's like
it's like you're you're way too freaking
early jordan i'm like oh
the guy from jurassic park
i've been really delving into game pass
recently and downloading xbox 360 games
which i'm all about just downloaded dead
space one and two very excited to play
i was tempted very excited to play 10
minutes of each of those
i was gonna hit the mass effect trilogy
even though i know that the legendary
edition was coming out that so i was
like i'm just gonna wait dragon age
origins though
download that first game again play
maybe seven minutes of that
i don't know man it's hard to get back
into dragon age origins it's kind of old
yeah just a little bottom eyes
lobotomize that first character what was
his name again
in the fade and then done get out of
there god
i really i really want to especially
with all the dragon age 4 stuff from
game awards
hey we've got some tangents here um but
i'm just actually tamjins we just wanted
to do a quick update on the improvements
in terms of like crashes etc on the xbox
side they mostly seem to be really
really stable i'm definitely just seeing
more people
complaining about problems with
playstation but
uh if you are having any issues with
your brand new consoles let us know
and also let us know what your kind of
customer experience has been like
um there have been a lot of mixed
reports people saying that sony have
been great and been able to actually get
them a new console
and then there's been the other side
where it's like sony just like not
acknowledging the issues at all
and just kind of saying hey you tried
turning off and on again those are the
ones that jim ryan is handling
personally
he gets every night he goes just just
right didn't happen and then reply
we are not hearing or seeing the uh
the hard drive thing this email is no
longer functional do not reply
and jam around peace
all right thank you everyone for
watching we'll be back again
next week talking about what we hope uh
and dream will happen with next gen
consoles in 2021 it's also gonna be a
nice little christmas day episode so
if you're fed up of talking to your
family or you're just ready to you know
just watch something pleasant in the
afternoon
make sure to tune in we'll see you next
week we're going to talk about my dreams
bold for some trouble
dreams about consoles oh okay
bye
you